[Musique]
nos trois analyses politiques ce soir
pour notre panel Émilie Nicolas Michel
COG et Christian Dufour bonsoir à vous
trois
bonsoir ce qu'on vous propose ce soir
mesdames messieurs c'est une sorte de
bilan de campagne c'est le dernier
vendredi de la campagne on est vraiment
dans le sprint final et on va voir ce
que nous analyses sont à dire de
performance de chacun des chefs alors
vraiment dans cet esprit de bilan en
commençant par monsieur Legault chef de
la CAQ qu'on écoute à l'instant
la question de l'urne je le répète là
c'est qui a la meilleure équipe pour
gouverner puis moi j'invite les
Québécois à faire l'exercice parce qu'il
y a cinq chefs mais il y a 5 équipes
demandez-vous demain matin qui serait
ministre des Finances qui serait
ministre de la Santé qui a la meilleure
équipe pour gouverner à moins interne ça
prend une équipe en économie qui est
solide pour transformer l'économie du
Québec en économie verte c'est pas rien
pour rendre le réseau de la santé plus
efficace c'est pas rien on n'aura pas
trop de 4 ans pour travailler là-dessus
alors il dit monsieur Legault que c'est
la question de l'urne en fait c'est ce
qu'il souhaiterait évidemment parce
qu'il pense que c'est à son avantage
Émilie est-ce que c'est la question de
chacun essaie de dire ce qu'il veut que
la question de l'autre soit mais la
notion existe pas et
ceci dit on peut comprendre François
Legault de vouloir que les gens pensent
à ça
durant dans la boîte de scrutin je pense
que ça va de soi avec son slogan qui de
continueront puis dans ce sens là il
pense que les gens connaissent notamment
son équipe bien bénéfice de la notoriété
puisque il y a plusieurs ministres
sortants bien sûr qui ceux qui se
représentent donc je pense qu'il y a
aussi là dessus et sur peut-être la
banque de notoriété de plusieurs autres
candidats pour dire que à ce sens là les
gens vont plus avoir une meilleure idée
de qui est l'équipe de la carque
justement parce qu'elle a été au cœur
des caméras devant les caméras
particulièrement durant la pandémie et
bien sûr durant tout le monde Michel
vous qu'est-ce qui vous a frappé dans la
campagne cette année de monsieur Legault
à part le fait qu'il était de très
mauvaise humeur ce qui est quand même un
signe de quelque chose durant la fin de
la campagne en particulier monsieur
Lebeau avait pas l'air de quelqu'un qui
est au-dessus de ses affaires alors
qu'ils sont d'âge montre qu'il est qu'il
devrait être au-dessus de ses affaires
il reste que la carte a perdu 5 points
durant la campagne ça c'est un point par
semaine dans une situation plus normale
c'est-à-dire où il y en a pas quatre
parties d'opposition à peu près à
égalité ce serait la différence entre
une victoire majoritaire et une victoire
minoritaire ou une victoire minoritaire
et là ça sera pas le cas mais
le fait que Monsieur Lebeau demande aux
électeurs voici la question de l'ordre
voici ce que vous devriez à quoi vous
devriez penser en allant voter
d'habitude
elle s'installe d'elle-même parce que
elle est partout dans la campagne il y
en a pour cette année la réalité c'est
qu'il y en a pas et que les gens vont
voter pour toutes sortes de raisons mais
l'avance de la cathételle et la division
de position est-elle les deux en même
temps coexistent
votre bilan vous de la campagne de
monsieur Legault je voudrais rappeler
tout d'abord mais que le véritable
jugement c'est lundi en fait tout à fait
que les électeurs et les électrices vont
le porter c'est bien beau les analyses
les commentateurs les sondages moi je
fais partie de ça mais je suis à quel
point c'était efficace ou pas c'est
lundi que ça va jouer moi une chose qui
me rend quand même un petit peu ironique
parce qu'on trouve que monsieur Legault
supporte pas très bien la critique et
c'est juste mais souvent c'est les mêmes
journalistes chroniques à qui durant la
crise sanitaire sont mis à pleuvoir
devant le gouvernement sans risquer du
tout trop longtemps donc c'est clair que
notre premier ministre j'ai perdu
l'habitude
il fallait se rappeler qu'on était des
démocraties libérales c'est un
unanimiste tout le monde était d'accord
avec le beau donc le prix des mauvaises
habitudes et là maintenant c'est vrai
que là les gens sortent on recommençait
à critiquer à critiquer critiquer donc
oui je trouve qu'en même temps quand tu
dis la question de Lyon c'est les gens
qui vont décider de la question mais
c'est vrai que sa force c'est moi c'est
bien beau le placottage lui il va dire
c'est des intellectuels mais moi je
gouverne le Québec depuis 4 ans j'ai
gouverné pendant la pandémie ça a pas
été facile faites-moi confiance à
nouveau et c'est un message qui a une
certaine puissance bon mais il reste que
il traîne des dossiers un peu comme des
boulets maintenant votre sujet préféré
Christian le troisième lien
je viens de voir sur la page facebook
c'est votre anniversaire donc joyeux
anniversaire
et vous nous faites un beau cadeau Julie
parce qu'aujourd'hui on parlait pas du
troisième lien principe je viens de
chantier
troisième lien ça c'est un exemple qui
montre à quel point et qu'on est
privilégié au Québec dans un monde où
les femmes en Iran se sont tués avec la
guerre en Ukraine les autres on s'est
permis ce déballer sur le troisième je
radote là mais je trouve que le
troisième lien c'est révélateur de
quelque chose au Québec on en a trop
parlé je sais pas si d'accord mais je
trouve c'est trop là quand même
peut-être il sera un des boulets ils
traînent un tas de boulet il y a
gouverner que voulez-vous quand on je
prenne juste à la défense de le goal
mais ce qu'on prend qui peut être
maladroit que c'est pas une intelle les
plus vieux mais de sous-estimons pas sa
force intrinsèque parce que vous avez le
Québec pendant 4 ans alors que les
autres ce sont des aspirants admirables
on va en parler tantôt moi je trouvais
que c'est une campagne plus intéressante
que prévu je serai fier d'être Québécois
après cette campagne là parce que je
trouve qu'on est chanceux d'avoir un tel
choix sauf le troisième lien mais ça
c'est intéressant on aura l'occasion
d'en parler on va faire le tour des
chefs quand on parle des boulets il y en
a un qui a été récurrent aussi pour
monsieur Legault tout au long de la
campagne on va l'écouter ici
tant qu'on n'aura pas stoppé le déclin
du français je pense que pour la nation
québécoise qui veut protéger le français
ça serait un peu suicidaire d'aller
augmenter
Émilie je vous donne la parole ici sur
le thème de l'immigration la façon dont
l'équipe de la CAQ parce que il y a
monsieur Legault mais il y a son
ministre aussi de l'immigration monsieur
boulet cette semaine qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de tout ça
un peu comme question je pense que ce
statut ça va être aux électeurs de
décider en fait ce qu'on en pense au
sens où je pense que il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui ont été blessées par les
propos qui ont été tenus au courant de
la campagne
pas seulement les personnes ayant reçu
de l'immigration je pense que beaucoup
de personnes qui tiennent à des êtres
chers qui sont sur l'immigrations qui
ont été aussi blessés par les propos
durant la campagne
ceci dit est-ce que ça fonctionne comme
comme un message pour une certaine
partie de l'électorat qui est d'accord
avec avec monsieur Legault je pense que
c'est dans l'urne c'est dans l'urne
qu'on va le voir si vraiment à quel
point les gens sont été choqués et je
pense qu'on va le voir de deux façons
faire par qui vote pour qui mais je
pense qu'on va le voir aussi par les
taux de participation je pense que les
compter
de qui ont où on a l'habitude de voir
des taux de participation assez faibles
on va voir si ce genre de déclaration là
ou ce genre de thème là dans la campagne
pas motivé certains électeurs à aller
voter parce qu'ils sont d'accord avec ou
parce que plus probablement sont en
désaccord avec François debout aussi
c'est que celui-là que ça fait justement
c'est plus un protestation qu'on se
décide d'aller voter donc en fait on va
j'ai hâte de voir ce que ça ce que si ça
va se lire dans l'urne et c'est aussi ça
va se faire dans les taux de
participation parlons du chef suivant
maintenant Dominique Anglade du Parti
libéral du Québec Michel ma question
finalement est-ce que elle réussit à
faire décoller sa campagne
la réponse serait répond par un seul mot
non elle n'a jamais déconné sa campagne
et c'est d'ailleurs ça le problème que
les libéraux a eu tout au long de cette
campagne elle était pas incarnée dans
les préoccupations des gens il faut pas
oublier le gouvernement provincial au
Canada ça s'occupe de préoccupation
quotidienne de la santé l'éducation des
choses comme ça proposer des choses très
éloignées de préoccupations quotidiennes
de l'électorale se lancer dans
l'hydrogène pour vendre peut-être à
l'Allemagne dans 20 ou 30 ans avec un
déficit d'électricité en attendant parce
que ça veut dire ça aussi
les gens ont juste pas embarqué avec ça
et je pense que Madame anglaise a été
prise avec cette plateforme là tout au
long de la campagne avec des engagements
qui étaient loin des préoccupations
quotidiennes des gens alors que les
autres parties je les mets je les mets
ensemble parce qu'ils ont pas mal tout
c'était pareil là-dessus avaient des
propositions qui étaient
qui était dans l'évacuation quotidienne
c'est ça la différence et c'est pour ça
qu'elle n'a pas aimé je pense
qu'on a vu quand même une Dominique
Anglade bon elle disait d'abord vous
allez me découvrir la vraie Dominique
enfin elle est allée pour le deuxième
débat avec ce la petite danse tout ça
mais on peut dire quand même que le
donner beaucoup d'énergie elle a fait
preuve de détermination où est-elle le
problème selon vous
la sympathie pour elle parce que c'est
triste cette situation puis vraiment mon
lundi j'ai beaucoup surveiller en fait
le score du Parti libéral le Parti
libéral c'est plus vieux parti du Québec
c'est le parti qui a démarré la
Révolution tranquille c'est un grand
parti qui avait un électeur off
francophone très large puis un électorat
non francophone est-ce qu'on va se
retrouver lundi avec un parti anglophone
ghetto un parti libéral excusez-moi qui
serait juste un ghetto anglophone est-ce
qu'ils vont garder le statut de position
officielle et quand à madame je trouve
qu'elle était piégée fondamentalement
parce que le fait un effort dans un
premier temps clair pour se rapprocher
de la majorité francophone parce que je
pense qu'elle était consciente du fait
que la marque lib était vraiment attaché
pour la majorité des francophones moi
c'est une chose qui me frappe des fois à
quel point il y a une animosité des
francophones d'ailleurs des libéraux
mais le problème c'est qu'en fait un
espèce de virage dans le domaine de
linguistique parce que ça posait pas en
fait sa tentative de se rapprocher des
francophones et je trouve ça lui a
enlevé beaucoup de crédibilité donc un
navire mais lundi ça va être important
de voir est-ce que le grand parti
libéral de la Révolution tranquille
est-ce qu'on reste encore quelque chose
ou là maintenant on est dans un parti
pratiquement ethnique d'autorisé
puisqu'il n'y a pas de micro-agar des
responsable de ça pas vraiment je trouve
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment son
problème l'hydrogène verte tout le monde
s'en fout là bon Emilie est-ce que vous
partagez la vie de Christian là-dessus
je pense que honnêtement il va avoir un
passe-martin vraiment important à faire
au niveau du parti bérale après la
campagne pour comprendre ce qui s'est
passé même depuis avant l'arrivée de
l'école Lab à la chefferie il y a une
démobilisation au niveau militant
au sein du Parti libéral depuis
longtemps et ça ne fait que s'empirer
dans sur le terrain les gens qui
remacent sur les côtés il manque
beaucoup beaucoup de bénévoles est-ce
qu'on parlait de la grosse machine rouge
le capable
exactement donc tout ça tout ça est
parti et je pense que beaucoup de gens
qui ont quitté le bateau avant même que
devenir en fait comme chef et ça
ce qui s'est passé à l'intérieur je
pense qu'il y a une histoire à sortir
publiquement il y a peu de militants
libéraux qui ont l'habitude de parler en
public quand il y a des choses qui vont
mal aux particules ou ailleurs on le
sait tout de suite c'est pas dans
l'habitude des temps libéraux mais je
pense qu'il y a vraiment une histoire à
écrire sur les transformations à
l'intérieur du Parti libéral du Québec
pour éviter justement de personnaliser
ce qui fonctionne et ce qui fonctionne
pas autour de la seule personne de
dominer je pense que le récit de ce qui
s'est passé que la partie minérale du
Québec depuis le départ de jean-charry
et quelque chose de beaucoup plus vaste
que la simple personne a été dominée
donc un gros gros post mortem à faire
après mais plus largement que sur cette
élection finalement mais c'est
intéressant c'est vraiment des questions
de fonds pour reconstruire
éventuellement après pour maintenir
l'avenir du parti falloir Quebec
solidaire Gabriel Nadaud Dubois un si
grand défi évidemment la croissance de
son parti son élan avec ça je vais
commencer avec vous là dessus qu'est-ce
que vous en avez pensé vous avez
l'impression qu'il commençaient bien sa
campagne mais que cette histoire là qui
a été nommée par ses adversaires la taxe
orange que ça coupait les lampes au
milieu ça vous paraît ouais oui ouais
ouais c'est ça je trouve que Gabriel de
Québec solidaire jusqu'à présent c'était
les nouveaux c'est le nouveau parti
là ils sont en fait un peu volés la
vedette par Paul simple
qui était tellement méprisé juste sibois
c'est facilement et puis aussi Eric
Duhem rituel il y aurait aussi quelque
chose même s'il y a rien d'autre même
s'il y a pas un député c'est quand même
fascinant quand on a un an et demi il
était rien et puis maintenant il y a une
crédibilité et un parmi les cinq donc
Gabriel a 12 mois puis Québec solidaire
ils sont redoutables parce qu'ils sont
très très forts chez les jeunes Gabriel
a 12 mois c'est un redoutable politicien
moi je trouve très stress idéologues à
un moment donné je trouve qu'il y a pas
tout à fait raison mais il reste que ils
ont pris le monopole quand tu veux être
l'opposition peut-être qui vont être le
puissance un peu ça le jeu jusqu'à un
certain point mais il y a quand même le
PQ qui semble jusqu'à un certain point
dans la joute encore on verra puis le
Parti conservateur de Dieu donc là juste
c'est compliqué c'est pas au bénéfice de
Gabriel de 12 mois qui aurait pu espérer
vraiment que ça soit clair que c'est lui
qui se pose au gouvernement de le groupe
Michel votre Bilan de la Campagne de
monsieur Dubois
vous avez parlé de la taxe orange tout
allait bien jusqu'à ce moment-là et que
le mec solidaire on le vit dans les
orages a commencé à plafonner à ce
moment-là c'était une taxidéologie
c'était une plaque une taxe qui
a attaquait beaucoup plus que le soldat
de l'aurait passé la classe moyenne un
propriétaire de triplex à Montréal est
un millionnaire il y a pas le train de
vie d'un millionnaire et ils ont
continué à la défendre tout au long on a
une taxe et grande fortune ça se fait en
France ça se fait ailleurs il y a plus
de grandes fortunes là-bas qui en est
ici là et s'aplombait un peu la campagne
et ça plombé la campagne malheureusement
au moment où on allait discuter de
d'autres enjeux que Québec c'est le
dernier maîtrise bien et qui sont très
en phase avec son électorat plus jeune
et entre autres la crise climatique et
c'est ce qui a fait que un peu plafonné
et qu'on a pas été porté autant par la
crise climatique qu'elle aurait pu être
comme
je pense que Gabriel à nous Dubois a
souhaité être la descente numéro 1 de
François Legault puis il y a eu il y a
eu son souhait un peu trop fort en fait
pour son propre bien lorsque c'est mis
par exemple dans le dernier des bas car
à recevoir toutes les attaques et à
devoir commencer chacune de ces
interventions par en
défaisant la désinformation avant de
lancer son message par exemple c'est sûr
que ça le met dans une position qui est
difficile que peut-être dû lui rappeler
la position dans laquelle il était en
2012 où avant de placer son message je
devais toujours se défendre d'être
essentiellement un démon sur terre donc
c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé je
trouve dans la deuxième partie de la
campagne avec avec Québec solidaire ceci
dit il y a peut-être aussi une
génération qui s'est identifié à cette
démonisation là et qui va souhaiter
peut-être sortir un peu plus voter que
ce qu'on aurait pu penser du moins je
pense que dans la dernière droite de la
campagne c'est vraiment ça sur quoi
Québec solidaire semble miser c'est sur
la sortie du vote des plus jeunes des
plus jeunes exactes
à faire alors on va y aller très très
rarement pour le PQ alors grosse tuile
aujourd'hui pour passer un appel à
Mondon qui est obligé de retirer deux de
ses candidats leur nombre vont rester
sur les bulletins de vote alors c'est
pour des propos anciens des propos à
caractère islamophobes est-ce que ça
vient changer quelque chose pour lui
Michel a vos yeux
non parce qu'il a fait exactement ce
qu'il devait faire il y a pas
tergiverser ces gens-là de font plus
partie de mon équipe même si maintenant
on va être sur le bulletin de vote bon
c'est dommage pour lui c'est difficile
quand on est un parti que de la
difficulté à recruter 125 candidats de
l'éviter comme il le faut ça c'est
évident mais je pense que Monsieur Serda
c'est bien flamandon a connu une assez
bonne campagne pour pouvoir dire mission
accomplie à la fin de cette histoire-là
quelle que soit le nombre de sièges
qu'ils auront
bon il semble souhaiter un retour des
anciens pékistes au PQ il y a des
publicités là-dessus mais ça sonne
quelque chose chez beaucoup de monde on
verra ce que ça donne un résultat il ne
reste qu'une minute il faut parler des
rituels Christian je donne la parole
vous avez vu ce sondage aujourd'hui qui
est sorti segment le soleil FM 93 là où
il n'est pas meneur dans la
circonscription de Chauveau qui le
choisit comment vous interprétez ça on
verra on verra
c'est que c'est un gros succès je le
répète pour Éric Duhem en un an et demi
d'avoir réussi à s'imposer comme un des
cinq mois je trouve les deux gagnants
les deux nouveaux c'est pas le
saint-père-pla mordant c'est la
découverte de la campagne et c'est Eric
du quel que soit le résultat lundi quand
même quelque chose par rapport à la
situation où ils étaient avant alors
voilà mais ça même Emilie un petit mot
sur monsieur
mais si il a pas de de cheval de Troie
qu'on va l'appeler ça comme ça dans
l'Assemblée nationale au moins
sa visibilité va être compliqué dans les
quatre prochaines années un peu comme
celle de Maxime Bernier en son nom
fédéral donc c'est plus ça que je vais
regarder je pense que le soir de la
soirée littéraire que ça soit lui que ce
soit quelqu'un d'autre ça change
vraiment la donne pour lui s'il y a
aucun député à l'Assemblée nationale
pour pour son organisation pour des
quatre prochaines années alors il reste
deux jours on va voir ce qui va se
passer dans ces deux dernières journées
par la suite le rendez-vous c'est la
soirée électorale de lundi merci
beaucoup pour votre regard sur
l'ensemble de la campagne aujourd'hui
merci